va a hacer algo más de un año que puse
en marcha un blog que titulé a quién
pertenece el pasado
el objetivo de este blog que era hablar
sobre historia pero no contar la
historia de las batallas de los reyes y
las citaciones que habían estado en el
mundo
el objetivo era preguntarse como
nosotros hoy nos apropiamos del pasado y
todo esto derivaba de una realidad que
me era muy habitual desde que como
español vine a vivir a guatemala ante
esa frase tan hecha que muchos chapines
me soltaban de cuando vosotros los
españoles vinisteis a conquistar nuestro
país es cierto confieso empieza a ser
mayor pero todavía no tengo 500 años
pero además me sorprendía que mi
interlocutor era capaz de estar seguro
de conocer a todos sus antepasados hasta
cinco siglos atrás y que propiedades
tenían esos sus antepasados de cinco
siglos atrás
y aquí es donde yo le pregunté en
realidad qué es lo que podemos poseer
del pasado
uno de inicial era podemos poseer el
tiempo el que ya ha transcurrido los
diez segundos anteriores quién es el
dueño de ellos ya no existen no están
nadie puede ser propietario de algo que
no existe y por tanto no somos dueños
del tiempo que ya no existe
pero imaginemos podemos ser propietarios
de la memoria
podemos decidir que solo pueden hablar
de la primera guerra mundial los que aún
sobreviven a este conflicto armado o los
nietos de los soldados alemanes
británicos y franceses que estuvieron la
batalla de verdún y eso que aquí otra
frase hecha que es mi habitual de todo
esto lo entiendes porque no eres de aquí
y sin embargo no la cuestión de la
historia es muy sencilla es una ciencia
más tiene un método si lo aplicamos si
lo desarrollamos lo que conseguimos es
información en realidad cualquier
persona puede investigar puede aprender
puede hablar sobre cualquier tema del
pasado la memoria no es exclusiva de
nadie en realidad la memoria nos
pertenece a todos de modo que tampoco se
puede poseer la memoria entonces cuando
hablamos de apropiarnos del pasado lo
que estamos hablando sobre todo es de
apropiarnos
de los objetos
de los monumentos de los territorios de
bienes materiales que vienen del pasado
y aquí es donde surge el problema porque
claro nos estamos dando bienes
materiales inevitablemente y hay un
propietario y la pregunta es quién tiene
que ser el propietario de los bienes
materiales que vienen del pasado
podríamos ocurrirnos un problema
imagínense que esta pluma de final de
servicio de 8 la tengo en mi casa
su primera idea sería qué tipo tan raro
qué cosas tan extrañas coleccionan
colecciona por hierros viejos pero
supongan sé que les digo no es que no
era mía la pluma la pluma no utilizó mi
tatarabuelo y quizás ustedes piensen su
tatarabuelo debía ser un tipo oculto
porque tampoco y tanta gente que a
finales del siglo 18 principios del 19
escribieran pero imagínense por un
momento que les digo que la pluma era mi
tatarabuelo que era josé cecilio del
valle no es el caso no es mi tatarabuelo
entonces imagínense que no fuera
entonces ustedes dirían cáspita para
mujeres la pluma con la que se hizo la
declaración de la independencia de
guatemala
a lo mejor nos pertenece a todos por el
claro algo tan importante como la pluma
con la que se hace la declaración de
independencia eso ya no puede ser
solamente mío no importa que yo lo haya
guardado muy bien como mi padre como mi
abuelo como bisabuelo de repente esa
pluma se convierte en una cosa tremenda
que se llama patrimonio histórico
nacional
y cuando nos cae esa losa es tremendo ya
no es nuestro es de todos bueno había
menos de todos estoy seguro que si van
ustedes a los museos de la zona 13 y
quieren tocar los objetos entre la
vitrina nos van a dejar podrían reclamar
lo podría ciudad que mía disfrutes de
todos me gustaría poder utilizar estas
ánforas que están aquí exhibidas no
suele ser el caso bien y sin embargo en
nombre del patrimonio histórico nacional
podemos hacer cualquier cosa y la
siguiente pregunta sería por qué esa
obsesión por conservar los objetos del
pasado para todos para el público en
general el tiempo en un ejemplo muy
simpático esto es el garaje donde steve
jobs con wozniak desarrollaron la
primera computadora apple
bueno hace menos de un año en la
municipalidad de los altos en california
decidió declarar el garaje de steve jobs
patrimonio histórico eso no significa
que le quitaran la propiedad a su actual
legítima dueña que es la hermana de jobs
sencillamente le dijeron desde hoy no
puedes tocar el gráfico
imagínense por qué más esto es que hay
un fulano en el departamento de cultura
de los altos que ha decidido que eso es
patrimonio imagínense que yo digo y digo
fíjense miedo cuenta que en su casa en
su habitación en su cama murió este
embajador nos parece importante desde
hoy no utilice su cama porque es
patrimonio de todos bien tampoco vamos a
meter a todos guatemaltecas una sola
cama estaría un poco apretados pero la
idea está en que no nos importan los
derechos del propietario cuando el
objeto se convierte en ese patrimonio
histórico y claro qué es lo que está
defendiendo realmente la municipalidad
de los altos está defendiendo el
patrimonio o está defendiendo la
atracción turística está asegurándose
que los ingresos de los mitómanos que
acuden a los altos a ver el garaje de
jobs van a seguir llegando
claro aquí ya el debate sobre identidad
cultural necesidad de reforzar la
nacionalidad y demás se va al traste
hay un interés económico que también es
legítimo pero sería más claro si lo que
sean por escrito hermanas de steve jobs
mala suerte su garaje nos da mucho
dinero le vamos a impedir que lo
modifique porque a la larga al final lo
que tendríamos que hacer sería preguntar
el propietario hoy hay usted que quiere
hacer con ese objeto que era suyo quizás
es un caso extremo muy llamativo sea el
de este sarcófago que les muestro aquí
aquí estuvo enterrado el rey es un asar
de sido no un tipo de fenicia hoy en el
líbano hay en la cubierta una
inscripción que dice esto es mi
sarcófago estoy enterrado dentro sólo
está mi cuerpo y no hay nada más me
gustaría que me dejaran en mi tumba y
que no abrieran el sarcófago bien por si
acaso alguno le hace lo maldigo será
impotente y se los brazos
pero a pesar de eso los arqueólogos
encontraron el sarcófago y lo sacaron de
su sepultura y en la actualidad se puede
observar en el museo del louvre
y no sé qué le ocurría a los arcos a los
activados en cuestión pero sarcófago
bien está donde su legítimo propietario
quería bien entonces imágenes de ustedes
que un buen día se muere los enterramos
y dentro 200 años cualquiera de ustedes
excavado y como ya tiene 200 años lo
podemos llevar un museo no sé si les
apetece nos aparece siempre hay
exhibicionistas puede ocurrir en
cualquier caso esta obsesión de pensar
que en el museo se va a conservar mejor
que donde su legítimo propietario quería
estar no deja de ser curioso bien y
seguro que no muchos de ustedes hasta
hoy se habían preguntado cuándo van a
los museos que estamos viendo bien que
lo que querían los dueños de esos
objetos hacer condición objetos bueno
cual es el poema que tenemos en los
museos el primer tenemos los museos es
que tenemos la obsesión de que todo está
bien conservado está mayormente guardado
y hay un problema inicial
están fuera de contexto esto que está
viendo ustedes aquí es un montón de
sigilata romana se utilizaban época de
los romanos para comer seguro que sin
lugar de veras amontonadas como están
ahí la tenemos puesta es una bonita mesa
con algo de comida al interior se
entendería un poco mejor pero el museo
tampoco se esfuerza por facilitarle la
lectura a los visitantes
bueno compres este la guía al final y
así lo entenderá con lo cual tenemos
doble beneficio ha pagado la entrada y
encima me compra un libro de modo que
tampoco estamos aquí para explicar en
las cosas
el objetivo es guardarlo todo muy bien
guardado
pero puede ser peor porque en esta
obsesión que tenemos de que todo tiene
que ser patrimonio histórico para la
sociedad ese conjunto y seguro que se lo
damos a un al mismo público lo va a
preservar mucho mejor que lo haríamos
nosotros en esta casa estos organismos
públicos también pueden perder los
objetos un caso muy singular ha sido
hace un año el ayuntamiento de madrid en
españa descubrió que le faltaban casi
200 obras de su colección
integran las esculturas 200 obras
imagínense sus padres o sus hijos se van
de fin de semana cuando vuelven a casa
les dices mucha mala suerte he perdido
el televisor el microondas la estufa las
cuatro camas el carro al perro la caseta
del perro entonces es increíble porque
hemos perdido todo eso no sé dónde está
supongo que ustedes se preocuparían la
mejor está se enojan pues bien en este
caso no es más que algunos los
responsables dijo bueno en realidad no
había un período de 20 años
tampoco más nada o sea no es para
protestar ahora pero hay un caso peor en
esa conservación que aseguramos a los
organismos públicos de el patrimonio
cultural y es que podemos manipular el
patrimonio histórico y cambiar la
historia
todos conocen el templo uno de tikal en
este templo uno de tikal aquí podemos
ver la restauración se parece
pero el arquitecto fue un tanto atrevido
a la hora de andar añadiendo escalinatas
y añadiendo cresterías pero podría ser
peor porque si miramos el templo uno en
su conjunto vamos a ver que ya en la
escenografía es absolutamente delirante
hemos puesto en conjunto edificios que
no fueron contemporáneos ya saben que
los mayas destruían una pirámide para
construir la siguiente además hemos
añadido esta bonita grama propia de
campo de golf
hemos dejado unos cuantos arbolitos muy
silvestres la parte posterior y está
todo limpio inmaculado
eso no es tikal en el mundo maya los
mayas no vivieron así y sin embargo es
lo que queremos vender estamos
fabricando la historia estamos generando
la historia que queremos que nosotros
como público y recibamos finalmente los
guatemaltecos no estamos tan mal porque
mirad con un pasado tan elegante como
este en el futuro va a ser realmente
brillante y aquí está la principal
preocupación sobre esa propiedad del
pasado porque en realidad que lo que
pretendemos hacer con el pasado
mi pregunta inicial de a quién pertenece
el pasado en realidad la pregunta que
tendríamos que hacer es
para que queremos utilizar el pasado y
esa es sin duda la gran duda porque en
realidad cuando estés va a ir a los
museos cuando van a leer un libro de
texto sobre historia cuando van a hacer
un recorrido con un guía turístico por
la antigua o por tikal lo que están
vendiendo es esta historia oficial
comprometida de identidad esa historia
que todos queremos para sentirnos
mejores como guatemaltecos que en
realidad es la manipulación de lo que
han decidido imponernos sobre lo que
tenemos que saber sobre la historia es
que ya saben las personas que vayan a un
museo no solamente traten de entender
para qué sirve una sigilata romana
pregúntense quién fue el propietario
como demonios llegó hasta esa vitrina y
por qué si es de todos ustedes no les
dejan tocarla
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]